hi this is presh talwalkar of
mindyourdecisions
and today i want to prove that pi is
irrational
this video will be based on a simple
proof by the number theorist yvonne
niven i have given a link to the paper
in the description for the video
before we get started
i will warn even though they call it a
simple proof this does involve high
school calculus
and the following concepts
with that caution in mind let's get
started
the proof
that pi is rational will involve four
steps the first step is to assume it is
rational that it can be represented as a
fraction a over b for integers a and b
the next step is we will define a
function f of x that depends on those
constants a and b
the third step which will be the most
important
is to prove
that the integral of f of x times sine x
evaluated from 0 to pi
will end up both being an integer
and it will be a fraction between 0 and
1.
this will be the contradiction and that
will allow us to prove that pi is
irrational
the first step of the proof is easy
by the definition of a rational number
if we assume pi is rational that means
pi
will equal a over b for integers a and b
from this we will define a function that
depends on a and b
the next step is to define the function
f of x
as
x to the n
times a minus b x the quantity to the
power n
all divided by n factorial
this seems like a complicated function
and it may remind you of functions the
taylor series expansion of functions
you've seen already like e to the x sine
of x or cosine x and this will become
important
the reason f of x is defined in this way
will become clear as we learn some of
its properties
so let's get to understanding f of x
a couple of properties we can see right
away
the first is that f of zero will equal
zero
this you can see directly by
substituting zero for x and you'll see
that term x to the n
will just multiply out everything to
zero
another property is that f of pi minus x
will equal f of x
this property is a little bit harder to
prove but it can be proved by direct
substitution
and the fact that pi equals a over b
i will leave the details of that proof
to you or you can read
i have provided a link to my blog post
where you'll see all the algebra
in this video i just want to say these
are properties
and will continue going there will be a
lot of details i will skip over
because there's some more properties we
have to get to
the third useful property of f of x
is that
all of its derivative its first
derivative its second derivative and so
on
evaluated at zero
will be an integer
this is something that will require
verification
but the general idea is that f of x you
can see it's a polynomial of degree two
n
and it has integer coefficients
so when you take the derivative and you
evaluate it at zero you're going to end
up with an integer value
so keeping this
property in mind that all of its
derivatives evaluated at zero are
integers
we can then derive the next property
which is that all the derivatives
evaluated at pi
each of those will also be an integer
this results follows from the fact that
f of pi minus x equals f of x
which we showed earlier
and then we use the chain rule to figure
out what the derivative of f evaluated
at pi is
it will be the opposite of the value
of its uh the derivative evaluated at 0
or the same value
and
since those were integers this will also
be an integer
so now we have four useful properties of
f
f of x
we will now get to something even more
complicated
we're going to define another function
which is
going to be uh the sum of several
derivatives of f of x
we're going to define g of x to equal f
of x minus the second derivative
plus the fourth derivative and so on
until we go all the way to the
derivative 2n
the reason we go to 2n is that f of x is
a polynomial of degree 2n
so beyond that all the derivatives will
be zero
so what's the point of defining this
function g of x which will be the
you know the sum of all of these
derivatives
well now we end up with some more useful
properties of g of x
the first property is that g of 0 and g
of pi are going to be integers
why is that
well we just showed that f evaluated at
zero and all of its derivatives were
integers
and f evaluated at pi and all of its
derivatives evaluated at pi or zero are
integers
so the fact that
f in all its derivatives at zero
uh and f in all its derivatives
evaluated at prior integers you put
those two facts together
to conclude that g of zero and g of pi
which are the sum of those
are also integers
there's another property of g of x which
will become important
it's the fact that the second derivative
of g
plus g of x
will equal the function f of x
this is pretty easy to verify
uh you can just directly compute the
second derivative g of x
and you'll see that all the terms cancel
except for f of x
with these properties in mind we're
going to go to
something just very cool about g of x
we're going to take the derivative of g
prime of x sine x
minus g of x cosine of x
now i'm skipping a lot of algebra here
but you can prove that the derivative of
that function
will equal
f of x sine x
the reason behind this is
the
if you take the chain rule of
derivatives
and you keep the property that the
second derivative of g of x
plus g of x equals f of x
after all that algebra you'll find out
that this function i've written out for
you will in fact its derivative be f of
x sine x
so why have we done all this work
we've done all this work because now we
know
a function whose derivative is f of x
sine x
in other words we figured out what the
antiderivative of f of x sine x is
so now we can get on to the step of
integrating f of x sine x
when we integrate f of x sine x we have
that antiderivative which we just showed
and we're going to want to evaluate that
antiderivative
at at pi
and subtract that from its value at zero
when you do that
i'm skipping a lot of algebra right here
you end up with the integral of f of x
sine x will be equal to g of zero
plus g of pi
a nice little result a compact way of
expressing the integral of f of x sine x
so what's important about this result
well we just showed that g of 0 and g of
pi are integers
therefore we've proven that this
integral of f of x sine x from 0 to pi
will also be an integer
so that's one step we're going to show
that this integral has to be an integer
now that we've come to that step we're
going to show the integral come up with
the integral in a very different way
so we'll get back to the properties of f
of x sine x
we're going to estimate this integral
and we want to estimate it on
the region 0 to pi
so we end up with this inequality
that f of x sine x
will be between zero
and the quantity a to the n
pi to the n
over n factorial
the reason for this
is that f of x sine x will always be
positive sine x is always positive and f
of x is a polynomial with
positive coefficients
the that's the for the reason why we
have uh the f of x sine x being greater
than zero
on the other hand
we have a upper bound for f of x sine x
and that comes from the fact of the
definition of f of x
which is x to the n a minus b x to the n
if you take that value at pi
it will definitely be greater
sorry it will be less than a to the n pi
to the n over n factorial
so we've created a bound
on f of x sine x
now what we can do is we can integrate
all three values
so if we integrate zero from zero to pi
we just end up with zero
if we integrate f of x sine x we end up
with the
integral
from zero to pi
and if we integrate a to the n pi to the
n n factorial
uh
that's just a constant term we end up
with another pi
so we have a to the n pi to the n plus
one over n factorial
so we can now
say that we know that f of x sine x the
integral has to be between zero it has
to be positive but it also has to be
less than a to the n pi to the n plus
one over n factorial
what does that mean
well so far we've said
nothing about a
the the value of n
n could have equaled one and could equal
two three a million ten million
but as as n gets larger there is
something that happens to a to the n pi
to the n plus one over n factorial
we can show that this term will tend
towards zero
as n goes to infinity
there are many ways to prove this
one is if you remember the taylor
expansion of e to the x
we have e to the a pi
will be the sum of a to the pi to the n
over n factorial
we know that that's a convergent series
so each of its terms a pi to the n over
n factorial must tend to zero
in any convergent series
each individual term has to go towards
zero
otherwise the series would never
converge it would just keep getting
bigger and bigger
the point of all this is we've proven
the integral of f of x sine x
will keep getting smaller as n gets
bigger
in fact for some sufficiently large n
we're going to have that this f of x
sine x this integral will be less than
one it will be a fraction
and that's the problem
why we'll put it all together
we've started out with the assumption
that if pi is rational then we can
create a function such that number one
its integral from zero to pi
uh will be g of zero plus g of pi this
will be an integer
and on the other hand
we found
using the same valid reasoning that we
can have that same integral be bounded
and as n gets larger it'll be a fraction
between 0 and 1.
now it's impossible that this integral
is both an integer and a fraction
between 0 and 1.
this is the contradiction
so now we can come to the conclusion
assuming pi is rational therefore leads
to a contradiction
therefore it must be the case that pi is
irrational
qed
i hope you have enjoyed this proof i
know it involved a lot of math
i want to thank you for watching i hope
you keep up with mind your decisions
either please subscribe to the videos or
you can also check out the website
or follow me on twitter